y es un día triste para la educación
nacional francesa son parte de las
palabras del ministro de Educación dai
al llegar a Sant Joan de luz en el país
Vasco francés donde esta mañana a las
diez una profesora de español de 54 años
Fue asesinada mientras daba clase
presuntamente por uno de sus alumnos de
16 años papánday de hecho se enteró de
la noticia en el consejo de ministros y
partió hacia el país Vasco allí También
recordó que son noventa los alumnos de
este colegio católico privado del oeste
del país que están siendo atendidos por
una célula psicológica y que nada hacía
presagiar un drama como este en este
colegio conocido por su seriedad y por
un clima social sereno también el
ministro de Educación afirmó que mañana
habrá Un minuto de silencio a las tres
de la tarde en todos los colegios de
Francia en memoria de la profesora
fallecida y que también mañana el fiscal
de bayona entregará los detalles de la
investigación policial que ha sido
abierta por homicidio con premeditación
justamente el principal acusado que está
detenido es un alumno de 16 años
serenamente Se puso de pie y atacó a su
profesora con un cuchillo dicen testigos
en el momento del ataque dijo que
escuchaba voces y que estaba haciendo
poseído otros alumnos hablan de él como
de un joven más bien retraído y
solitario sin embargo el establecimiento
no había hecho ningún señalamiento con
respecto a este